how do we find the determinant of matrix
a it is a one by one matrix one row and
one column what is the determinant of a
as there is just one element in the
matrix it will be written as the
determinant of that element determinant
of 2 what is this equal to the
determinant of 1 by 1 matrix is equal to
the only element that is present in the
matrix here the only element is 2 hence
the determinant of matrix a will be 2
this is the determinant of matrix a do
not misinterpret it as the absolute
value of 2 ok next question what will be
the determinant of matrix B the
determinant of B is written like this
and it will equal the determinant of
minus 1 the determinant of a 1 by 1
matrix is equal to the element inside it
it will equal minus 1 it's the
determinant of matrix B is finding the
determinants really that easy
what if it's a 2 by 2 matrix let's see
matrix X is a 2 by 2 matrix two rows two
columns and four elements what will the
determinants of X be equal to now this
is a 2 by 2 matrix the way in which we
find the determinant is totally
different from the way in which we find
the determinant of a 1 by 1 matrix it
will equal the product of these two
elements that's 8 times D minus the
product of these two elements that's B
times C yes a times D minus B times c1 1
F element times the 2 through eighth
element minus 1 to F element times the
two 1s element ad minus BC let's try it
out with numbers here's matrix C what
will the determinant of C be equal to it
will be the product of these two
elements that's 1 times 3 minus the
product of these two elements minus 2
times minus one the product of these two
minus the product of these two this will
equal 3 - minus 2 which gives us 5 the
determinant of matrix C is 5 now I want
you to try out the next problem what is
the determinant of matrix D pause the
video and find the determinant this
product is minus 1 times minus 2 and
from this product we subtract the
product of 3 & 4 this will equal to
minus 12 which gives us minus 10 the
determinant of matrix D is minus 10 so
finding the determinant of a 2 by 2
matrix is also not that difficult
but what about a 3 by 3 matrix how do we
find the determinant of a 3 by 3 matrix
we see that in the next session
you